[Music]
on this thursday night two neighboring
provinces
on very different paths ontario's plan
to reopen
gradually there are brighter days ahead
as manitoba
locks down further we're in the darkest
days
border battle the calls to reopen the
canada-us border
breaking news israel and hamas agree to
a cease-fire after so many lives lost
does it resolve anything on the ground
we're fighting for our
right to exist we have the story of one
neighborhood where palestinians face
eviction
so jews can move in what was once
submerged
reemerges the lost village that
reappeared after decades underwater
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight with news from manitoba
a province where events are making it
painfully
clear this pandemic is not over today
manitoba set a
record for daily new cases 603 new
infections
hospitals there are under so much
pressure they are now sending patients
to ontario
three coveted patients have been flown
to thunder bay ontario an eight-hour
drive from winnipeg
and there could be more hospitals in
northwestern ontario
are expected to take in as many as 20
seriously ill manitobans with the long
weekend looming provincial
officials say they have no choice but to
impose tougher restrictions
to try to slow the spread effective 1201
am
saturday and until next wednesday
outdoor gatherings with people
outside your household are banned only
one person per
household can enter a business to buy
essential items
and people are being told to stay home
as much as possible
i think we're in the darkest days of
this time with this pandemic
clearly the case numbers are are very
very high and unsustainably high
we need to suffer a little bit longer
so we can turn this curve like we've
done before
next door in ontario the situation is
looking more positive
infection rates there are dropping
vaccinations are rising
and premier doug ford has unveiled a
plan to gradually reopen
eric sorenson reports on what's in store
for ontarians in the days and weeks
ahead
it's beginning gradually some normal
activities will come to life in ontario
starting saturday
tennis golf and other outdoor recreation
i think it's been a long time coming i
know it's risky but i think it's time
still to come though three steps to
reopen the economy more fully
the first step outdoor dining more
retail business with limited capacity
some organized sports campgrounds and
bigger gatherings
but not until june the 14th a
disappointment for
those who wanted to see patios open
sooner it's been
challenging and frustrating especially
when we've done
everything we possibly could to ensure
that you know our dining experience is
as contactless as possible
the reality is covet 19
remains a significant threat to us this
is being done
slowly and with extreme caution
that is the only way it will work the
outlook has changed where it matters
most
in hospitals in april ontario modeling
suggested that cases in intensive care
could spike above 1500 potentially
beyond the capacity of the health care
system
public health measures averted a crisis
now
new modeling suggests that the icu cases
could drop below
500 by the middle of june the direction
of the pandemic
has turned and if we're careful and
cautious
we can maintain this momentum and this
momentum is what gets us to a good
summer
the provincial timetable in 21 day
intervals will open up more of the
economy as we get further into summer
and the hope is that vaccines will keep
case numbers and hospitalizations from
getting out of hand
even as we gather in bigger numbers and
these vaccines are extremely effective
at reducing
transmission as well as preventing
hospitalization and
these are things that will protect us
against things like fourth wave
reopening will depend on vaccination
rates and they are ahead of schedule
a cautious approach but suggests this
will not be a lost summer like 2020.
as long as it's done carefully i'm i'm
for it i think we're all eager to have
this over but i don't want to go back
into
a shutdown again it's not clear yet if
ontario will reopen schools for the last
weeks of june
the premier says scientific opinions are
split on that so stay tuned
eric sorensen global news toronto
vaccines are the ticket back to normal
life and canada is nearing a milestone
47.58 percent of eligible canadians have
received at least one dose of a covet 19
vaccine now
that means we are on track to pass the
u.s yesterday
47.59 percent of the american population
had received
at least one dose but on second doses
canada legs far behind
nearly four percent of canadians have
had two doses
compared to more than 37 percent of
americans
and it came as no surprise today that
the restrictions on crossing the
canada-us border were extended until
june 21st
that border will reopen at some point
and as jackson proskow reports pressure
is mounting there we go
as the u.s throws open the doors this
comeback
is ahead of schedule and as canadians
eye a cautious summer return
there's still no plan to reopen the
border closed for more than a year
if one person in canada was fully
vaccinated
that person should be able to cross the
border new york congressman brian
higgins has had enough
he wants both countries to allow access
for the fully vaccinated
and believes canada needs to ditch its
strict quarantine requirements
so all of those protocols that were put
in place in the absence
of vaccines to me are no longer relevant
neither the trudeau government
nor the biden administration is ready
for that canadian officials have said
they want at least 75 percent of the
population to receive
one dose of vaccine before seriously
relaxing domestic restrictions
the whole issue of opening up the border
with with the united states i think
obviously it's a very live issue
from a technical public health
perspective we're certainly looking at
the data add to that pressure from
premiers like ontario's doug
ford this is why i continue to call on
the federal government to do more to
secure our borders
who blames travelers for the arrival of
more contagious virus variants
the border is now so politically
sensitive that neither government is
willing to set reopening targets or
expectations
we are certainly always assessing as it
relates to travel
borders etc what we need to do and keep
in place in order to keep the american
people safe
all that uncertainty has led to calls
for some kind of clarity
now people need to at least have some
sense as to
what criteria are going to be used even
if they don't know the exact dates
so that canadians and americans know
what it will take
to eventually get back together with
most cross-border trades still flowing
freely talk of reopening the border has
become more of a public health
calculation
and with virus weary residents on both
sides of the border
that makes it a much more sensitive
subject donna
jackson proskow in washington thanks
after some provinces across canada
stop the use of the oxford astrazeneca
vaccine as a first dose
because of safety and supply concerns
there are fears thousands of doses could
expire and go to waste before they can
be used
michael couture looks at where all that
vaccine may end up
insane it is insanely frustrating sherry
langer got her first dose of astrazeneca
on march 19th and is due for her second
in three weeks but with so many unknowns
around that particular vaccine
the 69 year old is still weighing her
options
it's not that i won't get astrazeneca
it's that i will only get it if there is
absolutely no option for me to get an
mrna a
mrna vaccine is her preference because
the national advisory committee on
immunization
said those are the preferred vaccine
canada has a contract for 22 million
doses of astrazeneca
and some worry they could go to waste we
are privileged when it comes to
our position in the global perspective
and
we shouldn't be wasting any doses if we
can't use the doses we should send it to
someone who can
last week the former head of the vaccine
rollout said there were up to 270
thousand doses of astrazeneca in canada
that could expire at the end of june
thursday
in her first day in her new role
brigadier general christa brody
downplayed the amount at this point
we're tracking a very small number of
doses that will expire at the end of may
and we're working actively with the
provinces
uh to ensure that they can be used in a
jurisdiction
um that you know has the capacity to to
administer those
um before their expiry date it comes
just a day after newfoundland and
labrador said it has more than fourteen
hundred doses of astrazeneca
they could be sending back to ottawa
meanwhile doctors like neely kaplan
mirth are waiting to hear federal advice
on vaccine mixing
the ottawa doctor ran two jabapalooza
vaccine clinics recently
and she wants to hold another i need to
know as a family doctor
that i'm not going to let down all of
those people
who came to us for their first doses
they they did the right thing by getting
the first just that was available to
them
the deputy chief public health officer
of canada said nasi could be giving a
recommendation on dose mixing
by early june mike licouter global news
ottawa
canadian researchers are launching a
clinical study that could provide more
clarity for those who got oxford
astrazeneca as their first dose the
study will look at the safety
and efficacy of mixing different types
of vaccines
it will also examine the potential
consequences of delaying a second dose
by four months
researchers want to recruit up to
thirteen hundred adults in six provinces
the results are expected by july
now that nearly half the canadian
population has had their first dose of a
coveted vaccine conversations are
happening about what a return to work
might look like officials at all levels
of government have strongly encouraged
canadians to get the shot but it is not
the law and as ann gaviola explains for
employers
that can make things complicated
as companies across canada plan for the
new normal
many wonder what it means for their
workplace can employers require you to
get the jab
it's not something an employer can do
except in very extreme circumstances
where it's just impossible to do the job
safely unless you've been vaccinated
i'm thinking medical care hospitals
elderly care
while it's one thing for an employer to
say employees should get vaccinated it's
quite another for it to hold up in court
the employer would have to prove that
the job can't be done unvaccinated
and that there's no way to accommodate
[Applause]
even in healthcare it's not cut and dry
new brunswick premier blaine higgs has
tasked government lawyers
with figuring out if vaccination could
be a requirement for working in
long-term care facilities
unionized workplaces are a different
story because the union can come to an
agreement with the employer directly
it is a slippery slope though labor and
human rights laws protect a person's
right to choose
whether it's for health reasons or
philosophical ones and employers aren't
legally allowed to force workers to
share medical information
they can encourage and support
vaccination
like ecom timber corporation offering
350 dollars to vaccinated employees
workers who can't get the job for health
reasons can get the bonus too
we want this over with we want to get
back to normal as soon as possible and
this is the way to get there
but in most cases employers legally
can't force or
enforce a vaccination policy and they
have a duty to create a workplace that
doesn't pit workers against each other
on this polarizing issue
i'd say that there is a potential for
conflict in the workplace as it pertains
to
employees sort of taking the law into
their own hands if you will
um about you know if you have the
vaccine or if you don't have the vaccine
and workplace harassment and bullying
around that ann gaviola global news
toronto
a flash point for the violence in israel
you are stealing my house and if i don't
steer it someone else is going to steal
it
coming up the palestinian family is
facing eviction to make way for jewish
settlers
a ceasefire has been reached between
hamas and gaza and the israeli
government it was set to take effect at
7 pm eastern 2 a.m local time and it
appears to be holding
diplomatic efforts to broker this deal
went on all day
and so did the violence
up until a ceasefire deadline israel
launched more waves of heavy airstrikes
on gaza it says it targeted the homes of
tophamas commanders and their weapons
storage units
gaza also responded with more rocket
attacks
on israel after 11 days of airstrikes
the gaza health ministry says at least
232 palestinians including 65 children
have been killed thousands have been
displaced from their homes israel says
12 israelis including two children
have died israeli prime minister
benjamin netanyahu met with his security
cabinet today and late tonight came word
the operation in gaza will end the
american president joe biden had put
pressure on israel and called
egypt's president who has contacts with
hamas
egypt says a security delegation will
travel to gaza and
israel to monitor and help stabilize
this ceasefire
but this does not resolve any
long-standing disputes
there is a cycle to this conflict that
keeps repeating itself and it all stems
from a fight over land
that jews and palestinians both believe
belongs to them
that includes the sheikh jahrad
neighborhood less than a kilometer from
the walls of jerusalem's old city
israel occupies the territory something
most countries consider illegal
and now the palestinian families who
live there face imminent eviction
in order to make room for jewish settler
families israel calls it a real estate
dispute but
it is much deeper than that redmond
shannon has the story of one palestinian
family
with strong ties to canada
samira dejani budari and her husband
adele
most likely have just two months left in
the family house
she grew up in i'm thinking a lot about
that sometimes i
say talk to myself samira stop thinking
think about another things the israeli
courts which will
soon issue a final ruling regard these
cases in sheikh jarrah as
private property disputes between
palestinians and
jewish settlers it's easy to yell at me
but i didn't do this
you are stealing my house and if i don't
steal it someone else is going to steal
it no
the budaries and other families who face
eviction from the neighborhood
say it's the latest example of them
being forced out
and replaced with jews back in the 1950s
when samira's family arrived from
israeli west
jerusalem as refugees her father named
the new garden trees
after his kids unfortunately
my tree without leaves now and without
the
green branches but the roots are very
deep
so deep these latest proposed evictions
have led to protests
police scuffles and fights with israeli
settlers already in the area
eventually escalating into the deadly
air strikes and rocket attacks
this month when the state of israel was
founded hundreds of thousands of
palestinians lost their homes and their
land
and became refugees a few moved into
sheikh jarrah
supported by jordan and the u.n then in
1967
israel occupied east jerusalem including
sheikh jarrah
most countries still consider that
illegal jews with historical links to
the land
could claim ownership palestinians have
no equivalent legal right
to reclaim homes and land they've lost
this is one of the
pictures that i love the budari's
daughter rasha now lives in canada
and finds it hard to watch this play out
from afar
i'm so proud of what they're doing
speaking up
not giving giving up not never backing
down
the sense of community and how the
neighborhood residents just are coming
together
it's not a tenants versus landlord case
rather our we're fighting for our
right to exist to maintain living
in jerusalem a city where there's little
room left on which to build
and if palestinians leave they can lose
residency rights
we are both in the 70s
and to begin a new life in this age
it's not possible but on august 1st it's
likely
they will have little choice redmond
shannon global news
next what emerged when the water receded
an italian village is resurfacing for
the first time in over 70 years
it was once home to hundreds of people
before it flooded
as mike derlay reports it's almost like
a real life atlantis
pie up in northern italy tucked away in
an alpine postcard of a valley
sits the most curious of tourist
attractions a 14th century bell tower
rising above the cobalt blue waters
of lake asia the tiny village of quran
was put on the map
70 years ago when it disappeared against
the wishes of the town's people
italian authorities flooded the town to
make way for a hydroelectric plant
quran would become a curiosity for
divers
despite the low visibility in its waters
and when some writers were looking for a
locale for a horror tv show
quran fit the bill the lake has awakened
once again
the curse destroys everything hmm curse
eh
wonder what they say now that the
village has awakened
a few months ago the lake was drained
for maintenance leaving the town exposed
for the first time since 1950
yet because all the hotels are closed
due to covid nobody outside the region
seemed to notice
and only recently have visitors begun
looking around
steps probably were the entrance of a
house or a farmhouse
says this tourist canada has its own
quran
in alberta you can visit the resort town
of minnewanka landing
but you need scuba gear and 10
communities in ontario were displaced
when the st
lawrence seaway was flooded leaving some
towns abandoned
and untouched it's very eerie i mean
you walk through an abandoned ghost town
here in canada
and you get that eerie feeling as well
but when you're floating through it
it's a different feeling again and you
see things at a different level than you
would
as been walking on a sidewalk or on a
street
coron she says is interesting but given
the opportunity to see the saint
lawrence towns uncovered
she'd pass better to keep their
mysteries protected
by the waters around them mike drolie
global news toronto
and that is global national for this
thursday i'm donna friesen tonight's
your canada is lakeside park in st
catharines ontario thanks for watching
i'll see you saturday for the new
reality
take care of yourselves bye-bye